more pressure on boris johnson over
downing street party allegations after
he received a questionnaire from the
metropolitan police
on a visit to poland for talks on
ukraine the prime minister bought
himself some time on giving answers in
public i will have more to say on all
that when the process is complete
but now he's one of more than 50 people
across downing street asked to give a
reasonable excuse for attending alleged
parties
ministers insist mr johnson is focused
on his other duties and won't intervene
in recruiting a successor to cressida
dick as the new head of the force that's
investigating him i'm certain that he
will fill in the questionnaire but i
don't think people need to worry that he
has uh any intent to interfere more
broadly and what is the business of the
home secretary when quite frankly
there's lots of prime ministerial stuff
for him to be getting on with instead
lawyers claim sending questionnaires
which have the same status as an
interview under caution is unusual and
also point out that lockdown rules were
toughened between the first alleged
parties and the later ones the bring
your own boo's 20th may garden party in
2020
um the large gathering organization
offense wasn't in place then but by the
time you get to december and the later
parties
events gatherings
and that offence will be available
under 10 000 pound fixed penalty notice
the test is whether the event is
necessary for the purposes of work it's
not whether it's work related that's not
a defense in law
boris johnson is preparing to tell
police he denies breaking the law but
even if he is fined he's said to be
determined to fight on claiming he's a
democratically elected prime minister
with a huge mandate
but the pressure is piling up three
former tory leaders have criticized the
pm theresa may in the commons said john
major in a speech this week and serene
duncan smith who claimed it'll be very
tough for him to continue if he's fined
that's a view backed by other senior
conservative mps due process indicates
that
if
anyone
who is in a position of having made laws
then breaches the same laws i think it's
pretty difficult for them uh to continue
we above all people just have to stick
with them um whether you're a
backbencher or whether you're uh a
minister and that i think is just it's
that's the basic principle of respect
for the rule of law basically
having survived until parliament's
half-term recess the pm is at checkers
this weekend and he now has until next
friday to respond to the mets questions
john craig sky news